even without the iconic prologue crawl
or that classic a long time ago text
that precedes most entries in the saga
most people could be dragged into a
theater showing a Star Wars film they've
never seen and still know exactly what
they were watching within moments here's
why something really really bad always
happens pretty much every time a
bottomless shaft appears in a Star Wars
movie if the sagas heroes had any sense
at all they would have learned by now
that whenever they walk into a room with
a bottomless shaft they need to turn
around and run the hell away qui-gon
meets his violent end at the foot of one
of these impossibly long tunnels in
Phantom Menace both halves of Darth Maul
plummet down one of those shafts just
like Darth Vader hurls the Emperor down
one and Return of the Jedi Luke
miraculously survives a drop down Cloud
City's bottomless shaft in the Empire
Strikes Back and obi-wan hops over one
to turn off the Death Star's tractor
beam in a new hope the heroes of rogue
one also climb up one to get a hold of
the Death Star plans and then there's
the force awakens frankly Han should
have known better than to walk out over
one the shafts of Star Wars are legion
and if you see one you're probably in
big trouble Star Wars movies tend to be
bad for limbs and probably very kind to
black-market prosthetics dealers someone
loses a limb in most entries and whether
you're watching the movies based on
theatrical release or in chronological
order it's not going to take long before
someone loses something very important
to them Darth Maul loses everything
below his waist in Phantom Menace and is
revealed to have survived the ordeal in
the Star Wars 2 Clone Wars animated
series even making a cameo in so low a
Star Wars story Anakin Skywalker says
goodbye to the first of many soon to be
lost limbs when Count Dooku relieves him
of an arm and attack of the clones and
he loses the remaining arm in both legs
in Revenge of the Sith no major
characters lose limbs in a new hope
though obi-wan does leave a cantina
bullies bloody arm on the bar and later
loses his entire body if you'd want to
count that Luke takes off a Wampus hairy
arm at Empire Strikes Back
his father sends Luke's hand spinning
down a shaft later in the film and Luke
pays him back by taking off one of
Vader's already replaced hands in Return
of the Jedi
neither of the newest trilogies released
entries feature limb loss but both had
deleted scenes with amputations
Chewbacca tears off unkar
let's arm in a snipped force awakens
scene and the last Jedi originally had
captain phasma's hands sliced off by
Finn just before her death first
introduced in Empire Strikes Back Yoda
has proven to be one of the most popular
and oft quoted characters in the Star
Wars mythos from his first scenes in
Empire the Jedi Master earned a
reputation as a near bottomless font of
wisdom although with the advent of CGI
and the release of attack of the clones
the syntax challenged Jedi was able to
prove himself a badass warrior as well
but Yoda is also part of a Star Wars
tradition that doesn't begin or end on
Dagobah almost every entry in the
franchise includes at least one
character like Yoda someone who
initially seems physically unimpressive
but ultimately proves to not only be an
expert warrior but a source of great
wisdom and usually information about the
mysterious force even if the character
isn't a Jedi a new hope gave us obi-wan
the oldest hero in the film's ragtag
group who nevertheless easily saves loot
from Ponda Baba and later fights Darth
Vader in a lightsaber duel
Yoda fills the role in both Empire and
Return of the Jedi as well as appearing
in all of the prequel films cheerin in
way is arguably the most formidable
hand-to-hand combatant to appear in
rogue one as well as being the most
vocal supporter of the force in the film
the enigmatic Maz Kanata plays part in
the newest trilogy even though her
connection to the Jedi if there is any
hasn't yet been revealed people have a
lot of fun flying in Star Wars that's
not to say they shouldn't have fun
especially since they're usually just a
few minutes away from having their arms
chopped off and throwing down a
bottomless chef why not make the most of
it but it's still kind of remarkable
just how much fun they're having and
there's an almost endless stream of
Wahoo's and yeehaw is to be heard
throughout the sagas many stories and
they usually happen in the cockpit of a
spaceship
whether it's Han celebrating finally
taking out a TIE fighter or even the
young Anakin Skywalker belting out the
occasional wahoo while threading through
Trade Federation droid fighters Star
Wars heroes really like to yell even
when they're having a really bad day
take Finn who when he first escapes the
clutches of the first order with though
is wallowing up and down the dark void
of space as he and his new buddy both
narrowly
scaped death while the Star Wars
Galaxies boasts a wide variety of
planets the planets themselves don't
tend to offer a wide variety of climates
and terrains in fact the worlds of star
wars tend to be planets of extremes
while our own earth has a few deserts
for example if there's a desert on a
planet in a Star Wars film that it's
likely because the entire planet is a
desert like the reoccurring setting of
Tatooine or force awakens jakku if
there's ice and snow on the planet
there's ice and snow everywhere like the
frigid planet Hoth in the beginning of
Empire Strikes Back
there's the swamp planet Dagobah the
ocean planet Kamino and the volcano
planet Mustafar and Revenge of the Sith
the final location in Return of the Jedi
is even referred to as the forest moon
of Endor in case visitors aren't quite
sure of what extreme and singular
environment they should expect speaking
of extreme planets how about this no
matter what the story is about or who
the lead character is the Star Wars saga
just keeps on bringing us back to one of
two desert planets usually it's Tatooine
though Tatooine is replaced by the
equally desolate and arid jakku in the
force awakens even the rise of skywalker
is supposed to add the star wars roster
of desert planets with the strange
rockin world of personna now it is a
little surprising that Tatooine in
particular features quite so much in the
Star Wars mythos if for no other reason
than a series set in a galaxy chock full
of planets inhabited by intelligent life
keeps swinging back to the same dry ball
of sand well if there's a bright Center
to the universe you're on the planet
that is farthest from while the question
of tattooing specific connection to the
force has yet to be directly addressed
in the films it would be surprising if
it's reoccurring appearances had nothing
to do with a strong connection to the
force from Luke's training on Dagobah
and Empire Strikes Back and Rey's time
spent on octo in the last Jedi we know
certain places in the universe are
particularly strong with the force
considering Tatooine is the birthplace
of Anakin Skywalker the childhood home
of Luke Skywalker and the decades-long
hiding place of obi-wan Kenobi it's
probably fair to say that the place has
at least some kind of significant
connection to the force as a whole the
universe is a big place and the Star
Wars galaxy hides many titans star wars
boasts enough giant monsters to fill the
cast of any decent Godzilla flick
unlike most of the monsters in Godzilla
those Star Wars Titans are weirdly good
at hiding especially considering their
size often these monsters even appear as
naturally occurring parts of the terrain
most famously there's the mighty Sarlacc
of Return of the Jedi who swallows Boba
Fett and dozens of Jabba the Hutt's
henchmen from afar the Sarlacc looks
like nothing more than a huge hole in
the ground but once you get close enough
to spot the teeth in the tendrils you're
probably already lunch equally sneaky is
the gargantuan space slug of Empire
Strikes Back who almost makes a meal of
the heroes when Han mistakes the beasts
insides for a cave then there's a die
enoguh the beast who almost drags Luke
to his death in the trash compactor
scene of a new hope and who mostly
appears off screen the rancor though not
exactly as cleverly hidden as the
Sarlacc or the space slug is kept out of
sight for its first few scenes in Return
of the Jedi there are also the multiple
aquatic Giants who threaten the heroes
of phantom menace as they navigate
Nobu's waterways and then of course
there's the massive tentacle suma vermin
Oath who tries to devour the Millennium
Falcon in solo droids don't do what
droids are supposed to do or more
commonly they do what they're supposed
to do but only after complaining about
it for a really long time c-3po is
constantly arguing against the heroes
plans and r2d2 is usually preoccupied
with some secret mission in rogue one k2
second-guesses all of kasi ins decisions
and sets himself up as the authority on
who can and who cannot be trusted
while on solo l3 is more concerned with
starting a droid revolution than with
being helpful ironically perhaps the
best evidence of this is in the rare
example of a droid doing what it's
supposed to do in Phantom Menace r2d2 is
introduced as one of a number of droids
who are dispatched to repair Queen
Amidala ship while under fire artoo is
the only droid to survive and manages to
fix the ship's hyperdrive later Amidala
thanks to droid for its service and
orders it to be specially cleaned as a
reward which means apparently a droid
doing precisely what it was designed to
do is such a rare occurrence in the Star
Wars narrative that when it actually
happens any nearby humans feel the need
to set up a freaking award ceremony the
Maus Eisley cantina from a new hope is
the setting of one of the franchise's
most well remembered scenes and also one
of its most replicated sim
hives of scum and villainy can be found
in just about every Star Wars film
Jabba's palace in Return of the Jedi is
basically a larger grander version of
the moss eisely cantina
in one of attack of the clones few
genuinely funny moments obi-wan uses his
Jedi mind trick to convince a drug
dealer in a bar on course on to rethink
his path in life fittingly solo features
almost nothing but these places of ill
repute starting with the crime boss lair
han escapes on Corellia the casino on
Vandor where han first meets Lando and
later the bar on Numidian prime where
han finally wins the Millennium Falcon
from Lando shortly after han meets finn
and rey in the force awakens he brings
them to maz kanata's cantina esque
castle on takodana and while its leader
and soldiers were extremist rebels
rather than bounty hunters and criminals
saw guerreras stronghold on jetta felt a
lot like Jabba's palace then there are
the examples to see more upscale but are
nevertheless just as villainous like
dried and vas yacht in solo and the
casino that caters to the super-rich
residents of Kanto bite in the last Jedi
their fancy sure but that doesn't make
them any nicer obviously if you're gonna
have a bunch of hives of scum and
villainy in your galaxy spanning epic
you're going to need some actual scum
and villains to populate them luckily
the Star Wars mythos has no shortage of
smugglers bounty hunters organized crime
bosses and other assortments of crooks
and criminals
han Solo pretends to be the very picture
of apathy in the face of the Empire's
many crimes but eventually his heroism
does shine through Lando joins him in
Empire Strikes Back and Solo introduces
us to even more rogues like Beckett and
Val cassian of rogue one is a different
kind of scoundrel though while solo acts
as if he only cares about himself but
nevertheless always winds up doing the
right thing
Kassie intends to do the wrong thing for
completely unselfish reasons like when
he murders another rebel operative in
the beginning of rogue one stop him from
being captured and revealing rebel
secrets or when he becomes more than
willing to murder Galen or so for the
sake of the rebellion one of the most
recent additions to Star Wars list of
famous scoundrels is DJ in the last Jedi
with DJ the storytellers turned the
usual figure of the Star Wars scoundrel
on its head the audience is led to
believe the DJ is another reluctant hero
simply feigning selfishness but he turns
out to be exactly what he seems
betraying Finn and rose to the mercies
of the first
order one of the funniest ironies of the
Star Wars saga is just how many of its
major characters have no idea who their
parents are in our comparatively
technologically primitive grill world
just about anyone in the United States
could mail a DNA sample off and
potentially find out what part of the
world their ancestors hailed from but in
a galaxy far far away technology seems
to be far superior to our own and no one
seems to have heard of DNA testing while
speculation about Rey's parents is still
running wild she's hardly the first
character in the saga to face a mystery
surrounding her birth Luke Skywalker
learned Star Theatre as his father at
the end of Empire Strikes Back and Leia
who unlike Luke has met who she believes
to be her biological father and has less
reason to believe there was anything
mysterious at all about her birth learns
she's Luke's sister in Return of the
Jedi then of course there's Vader
himself in Phantom Menace Anakin's
mother Shmi tells qui-gon her son has no
biological father one day she wasn't
pregnant and the next day she was
without any inciting events and that's
about as mysterious as it gets a Star
Wars movie with no lightsaber fighting
is surely no Star Wars movie at all
an elegant women
but um all civilized a in the earliest
films that dual usually takes place
toward the end obi-wan battles Vader in
a new hope
Luke's Empire Strikes Back fight with
Vader's perhaps the most iconic of all
the duels and once he's fully trained
Luke proves his skills superior to
Vader's in Return of the Jedi the
prequels brought us the manically
choreographed battle between Darth Maul
qui-gon and obi-wan and Phantom Menace
obi-wan and Anakin are both humbled by
Count Dooku in attack of the clones
though they're saved when Yoda bursts
out his crazy lightsaber skills for the
first time on screen Revenge of the Sith
was the first film to deliver a duel
right at the beginning a rematch between
Anakin and Dooku along with the Jedi
councils doomed attempt to capture
Palpatine general grievous for armed
assault on obi-wan Yodas fight with
Palpatine and Kenobi's victory over
Anakin on most afar the force awakens
was the first time the series portrayed
a woman on either side of a lightsaber
duel as Rey takes on kylo Ren after the
latter easily defeats Finn weirdly
there's little saber on saber action in
the last Jedi kylo and Rey fight back to
back against snoke's elite praetorian
guard finn uses an energy baton rather
than a lightsaber when he attacks Basma
and the luke who faces kylo at the end
of the film turns out to not have been
there in the first place
the only instance in which one
lightsaber physically clashes with
another actually takes place during a
flashback Star Wars climax is tend to
follow one particular multi-layered
formula in the sense that there's
usually one main conflict made up of two
or three smaller battles usually there's
at least one large scale military clash
contrasted against a much more personal
one-on-one fights Return of the Jedi
establishes the formula on Endor the
Ewoks in the rebel ground forces fight
the imperial troops to take out the
Death Star shield generators and in
space the rebel fleet clashes with the
Imperial TIE fighters and Star
Destroyers meanwhile on the Death Star
Luke and Vader cross lightsabers one
last time the formula returns in Phantom
Menace
the Gungan army faces off against the
droids on Naboo obi-wan and qui-gon had
their fateful duel with Darth Maul in
the palace while Naboo fighters battle
the trade Federation's droid ships in
space likewise the end of the force
awakens is split between the rebel
fleets attempt to take out Starkiller
base and the lightsaber duel in the snow
road
one's tragic final clash depicts yet
another space battle a large-scale
ground assaults and the efforts of Jin
casseon and k2 Esso to find and transmit
the death star plans revenge of the sith
is one of the few entries to not include
a huge military battle instead going
back and forth between the obi-wan &
bader duel on Mustafar and the fight
between Yoda and Palpatine on Coruscant
a New Hope's all-out assault on the
Death Star actually seems pretty simple
in comparison check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]